president Trump coast of Virginia this
morning to celebrate an important moment
for the state's first colonial settlers
the trip is being overshadowed by his
ongoing criticism of Democratic
congressman Elijah Cummings where race
has been invoked
Errol Barnett is in Williamsburg
Virginia ahead of the president's visit
Errol how are local lawmakers responding
to the feud well Anthony with some
resistance Virginia's Black Caucus is
boycotting the President's speech today
for what they call his racist rhetoric
and attacks on black lawmakers all of it
they believe makes him ill-suited to
commemorate this historic moment
meanwhile the president met on Monday
with the group he described as
inner-city pastors which included the
niece of dr. Martin Luther King junior
evangelist alveda King was among a group
of pastors invited to meet behind closed
doors with President Trump at the White
House Monday King like fellow attendee
Reverend Bill Owens of vocal supporters
of the President and defended the
meeting it was two hours of discussion
for several weeks
president Trump has increased attacks on
congressional people of color who've
been critical of him calling congressman
Elijah Cummings racist and tweeting that
for female Democrats should go back to
the quote crime-infested places from
which they came on Monday president
Trump called the Reverend Al Sharpton a
con man who quote hates whites and cops
if he really thought I was a con man
he'd be nominating me for his cabinet
Sharpton criticized the president for
his attacks on Cummings and his district
which includes Baltimore he has a
particular venom for blacks and people
of color the event today in Virginia
takes place four hundred years since the
first legislative assembly set the
foundation for American democracy Kathie
Spangler is overseeing the commemoration
some black lawmakers are boycotting
parts of the commemorative event because
it includes president Trump the reality
is this is our democracy and we invite
all Americans to be part of the
conversation and the struggle and the
challenge of that conversation that's
more authentic and genuine that's what
we need
now organizers wanted today's event to
be a message about American unity but
underscoring just how divisive the
president's rhetoric is the state's
black lawmakers will hold a separate
commemorative event this morning at the
same time in a completely different
location
Michelle unity clearly needed in this
nation Erol thank you